Paul Ryan has gone completely off the
rails and is now pushing to phase out
Medicare and replace it with private
insurance the opportunity is now there
for Paul Ryan with a Donald Trump
presidency now it's one of these real
possibilities that becomes more real
with a unified republican government
Donald Trump has won the White House
Republicans will control the Senate
Republicans will control the house
Medicare is one of the most popular
government programs in the u.s. period
it is also one of the most effective
government programs in the u.s. period I
want to put this in writing for you so
we can actually look at what Paul Ryan
said here when being interviewed by Bret
Baier Bret Baier said your solution has
always been to put things together
including entitlement reform that is
Paul Ryan's plan that's not Donald
Trump's plan and Paul Ryan went on to
say well you have to remember when
Obamacare became Obamacare Obamacare
rewrote Medicare rewrote Medicaid if you
are going to repeal and replace
Obamacare you have to address those
other issues as well what a lot of folks
don't realize is this 21 person board
called the IPAB is about to kick in with
price controls on Medicare what people
don't realize is because of Obamacare
Medicare is going broke Medicare is
going to have price controls because of
Obamacare Medicaid is in fiscal straits
you have to deal with those issues if
you're going to repeal and replace
Obamacare Medicare has serious problems
because of Obamacare those are part of
our plan now some people have seen this
and they say David he's not saying phase
out Medicare just look at Paul Ryan's
own website which currently says that
people will be able to keep Medicare
supposedly but no more Medicare for
future retirees and instead what will we
replace Medicare with private insurance
and subsidies to help seniors afford
private for-profit health insurance
this means get rid of Medicare Pat this
means take even more health care in the
United States and put it in the
for-profit world it means if you haven't
gone on Medicare yet when you get to
that age there will be no Medicare if
Paul Ryan gets his way and this reminds
me a lot of President Bush's attempt to
privatize Social Security right to the
benefit of corporate interests but it
was so overwhelmingly unpopular his
proposal and his poll numbers dropped
people don't want you to touch Social
Security they don't want you to touch
Medicare it's overwhelmingly popular I
hope you are right that the voice is
saying don't touch it will prevail and
there is a really good way Republicans
typically have older voters supporting
them at much higher rates than younger
voters a good way to turn off older
voters is to say hey we're gonna do away
with Medicare instead we'll give you a
little money for private for-profit
insurance and you will hear people
saying this is reform David or using
other catchwords Medicare is a
single-payer universal health care
system research makes it abundantly
clear that it's more efficient and
keeping costs down and provides better
care than private insurance what Paul
Ryan is suggesting is not reform it is
saying no more Medicare we are now
putting even more people's health in the
sort of on the ledger for-profit
insurance companies will be able to
decide and there is one mathematical
reality about how to deal with the
growing aging baby boomer population
which is take away their health care and
a lot of them will start to die this is
an issue that progressives must activate
on and we will be talking about this
more with the upcoming fundraiser that
we are doing